the reason why he won after he lost
is because his stock didn't go down
after a loss
your stock's supposed to go down a
little bit yeah and he got he lost most
of those rounds the last round he almost
knocked his ass out
and uh nate diaz almost knocked leon
edwards out we're talking about the ufc
fight this weekend
um but there's a perfect example we're
like that's just the realest
[ __ ]
gets his ass kicked for most of the
fight last round almost knocks the
[ __ ] out and finishes his ass
and it's like that's what we want from
nate diaz and to be honest
i hit jake uh paul after watching that
fight and i was like
you got to fight an abs that tyron
woodley fight
yeah cool do it if you want i don't care
do y'all care no no i thought i cared i
don't no i don't care never did god
bless tyron he's a sweet guy
and he was a [ __ ] ufc champion but he
doesn't have that
gravity right like i don't i'm not like
what is tyron doing today what's going
on in his life like ben askren had that
gravity
there's something about ben you're just
curious about his life he's he's good at
[ __ ] talk he's great at [ __ ] talk
i didn't really care but then when i saw
him [ __ ] talking jake at the press
conference i was like this is good this
[ __ ] good guy's good
there's something about him you're just
drawn to him nate has that
that raw pure authenticity oh yeah and
you're just like i need to see this
[ __ ]
that fight jake paul versus nate diaz
is the biggest fight in fight sports
right now i mean maybe if mcgregor gets
involved in some way
mcgregor gets involved that's it that's
over but i'm telling you nate diaz
versus jake paul boxing match would be
through the [ __ ] roof one and a half
million minimum
one and a half million i mean i'll
cancel the tyron woodley fight
cancel him pay uh tyrant off here's
whatever you were gonna make in a fight
you got your money nate let's go
when you're healed up let's [ __ ] go
that fight would be unbelievable you
have the villain
and you have the anti-hero but now we
get to root for the anti-hero
yeah it's like a [ __ ] ocean's 11
movie yeah like the good guys aren't
even that good
right but you're right but jake is so
compared to the bad guy yes yeah yeah
and jake knows he's [ __ ] hated and
he's leaning into it
and he gets to be hated against the guy
that everybody wants to like for being
bad
i'm going to teach him a lesson from the
streets i mean that is a build-up
yeah who wins that fight you think i
think if it's a boxing match nate
nate wins i mean nate's been boxing with
some of the best like uh
a sparring partner with some of the best
boxers in the game but
i think that you could sell it oh yeah i
think you sell it
but but that was two but that what were
we just saying
you were calling me out oh rightfully so
but you were calling me out
like um fighting determines who like
wins it shuts the argument up
yes yes yes yes and and i don't think
anybody thought that logan beat
uh floyd but the expectation of what was
going to happen he beat
yeah he beat the expectation exactly as
long as you beat your expectation
maybe that's what happened with nate
people like yo leon edward is going to
just destroy this guy
and then it went five rounds and in the
fifth round nate almost
finished him in the last minute so you
beat your expectation
you win you know in in in a weird way
you see what i'm saying and and i would
only talk about uh define wins as tk or
ko
everything else up to the the scorecards
is a debate yeah the debate will still
happen but
you get a lot of that [ __ ] out like we
how much we're gonna keep fighting
arguing after we fought you can't still
talk [ __ ]
i'm tired bro you're tired you saw what
i did to you yeah we got it all out even
if it's like close and you don't know
who won
we got it all out it'll calm down the
argument because it's like hey we
we did this do we want to do this again
yup we already did this yes i'm tired
you're tired right
this is how we get the purge bro i'm
telling you this is how it starts
move towards the purge we're going to be
at the perch within two decades there'll
be a perfect nah but purge is too much
it starts like this like let's just have
people fight one another and it'll be
one day of fighting i think in some
south american um country there's like a
small town
somebody look this up if you can where
one day a year
they settle their disagreements through
fist fights oh i do this fight is fine
i think that is it but the per if it's
more than one like we just went [ __ ]
up one dude we're not getting
anything out yeah yeah you know what i
mean but if you fight one-on-one you're
you're both getting all your [ __ ] out
and then it's done but you know people
got too much pride they don't want to
lose a fight so immediately guns are
being pulled out
if we had a purge day that's why we're
purging in south america they can't
they're beating each other with bamboo
or something like that
whatever they have takanakua in peru
in peru yeah fists only fists it's a
fistfight [ __ ] are fighting you just
settle all the scores and then move on
to the new year it's beautiful
public brawl offers an alternative
method to resolve conflict
that's it let's get it out of the way
son let's get it out
you know when they you don't want to
know when they do it december 25th
yeah that's right that's right
shout out to the j man so here we go no
everyone's off work we got our whole
family here like
let's do it it's not nothing to do with
jesus like yo we off like
we got [ __ ] to do it's christmas we
won't get these presents
real talk morning and night i don't know
whole day all day bro
can you go open christmas presents and
get your ass kicked ass
sucks come on y'all got this i think
that we got i think we're on to
something i think we'll be at the purge
we're american we always take [ __ ] next
level
[ __ ] get regular tattoos on
their arm we get that [ __ ] in the face
you know what i'm saying somebody get a
tongue ring we gotta split the tongue in
half
we always take it to the next level
we'll be at a purge within two decades
because that's how we'll need to handle
[ __ ] and loki purge is kind of [ __ ]
if you're using weapons yeah the beauty
of a fight is
this is me and you it has to be a fist
i'm telling you fists
then you get it out then you're letting
all like if you're shooting somebody
you're not getting like
you're getting anger out but you're not
tired if you fight somebody you're
[ __ ]
tired i got all my emotion out of me you
still gotta hug afterwards yeah yeah
you gotta hug afterwards people just
need to get punched in the face more
often than you think
i've been told that about me many times
[Laughter]
100 yeah i think i think a good punch in
the face
or just understanding their
repercussions for actions
you know i mean it's a lot of talk but
then there's no dude i think as a
as a society you get annoyed with no do
every once in a while you need to see
some do why are we watching
people who do this for a living fight
why like that is what they do for a
living
and probably make millions of dollars
which is absolutely absurd i don't mind
seeing that guy get his ass kicked
though
exactly once i watch his tic-tocks now i
want to see him lose that fight you
don't think that everybody watching that
was happy as long as one side of the
other got beat like
nobody was rooting for anybody but pain
you're yeah down barely scraping enough
pennies from your [ __ ] stimulus check
to pay for this pay-per-view just so you
could
see these [ __ ] that make
millions of dollars doing that hurt
and bleed yeah satisfaction fire no
matter who gets hurt
you feel good oh yeah this is amazing
we need to fight politicians
who gonna take on biden oh who's gonna
take on biting
a problem i would i'm not gonna fight
biden but i'll do a five saltines and
under a minute challenge with him
[Laughter]
i will have a eat five saltines in under
a minute challenge with joe biden
president joe biden
that might be elder abuse bro do you
think that's abuse i think it's elder
abuse
i don't know cuomo might just put him in
a nursing home and kill him or something
yo
that could [ __ ] happen yeah that's
what i'm saying yeah yo
do we have to call out the cuomo's real
talk
i think you did yeah you kind of did
that i think you pointed at the camera
how tall is that we need to learn about
that [ __ ] oh real quick i have the
follow-up to the jake paul uh nate diaz
fight if they fight yeah he's uh he's
six two
eight six two six two hundred ninety
five pounds [ __ ] you
i'm knocked that [ __ ] i'm
knocked out
nakamoto [ __ ]
that might happen whatever ain't a gay
pride month
[Music]
boxing boxing boxing boxing bare
knuckles boxing
fighter he was going around punching
[ __ ] no that's crazy bro you
can't be going around punching people
that's crazy
i mean you just said the purge yeah but
the purge is like yo let's
let's knuckle up let me you know what i
mean you can't be waiting for the bus
and someone punches you that's nuts yeah
but this is what we do just knuckle up
because that's possible
if you're not wrestling the purge that's
fine that's part of the rules i'm
wrestling no [ __ ] who cares
about pride month this so much
i might wrestle him you know july first
when he
[ __ ] all done no more coming his
balls you know what i mean when he's
done celebrating maybe i'll wrestle him
but i'm not going to wrestle him in the
middle of june hey no december 25th
chris
chris cuomo versus andrew schultz let's
do it christmas day christmas day
hey christmas day hey i'm not against it
bro i'm only going after politicians
or media personalities bro
you